Film Courage: How old were you when you arrived
in Los Angeles?
Choice Skinner, Actor, Director and Acting
Teacher: Oh, that’s a good one.
Ooh…I don’t want to lie or get it wrong…I
was….
Film Courage: What hit song was out?
Choice Skinner: That’s a good one.
That I remember.
Aaliyah’s ‘Are you that somebody?’
I remember that being on…listen moving to
Los Angeles was like a serious culture shock.
Okay, because I came from Atlanta/Augusta
And lived there for years and then I had this
R and B artist that flew me out around Thanksgiving
time and we were working on this second album
(which never saw the light of day unfortunately).
But I remember going down the 101 because
the 101 always freaked me out.
It was just like I’m not used to these types
of freeways and I remember ‘Are you that
somebody’ by Aaliyah being on…because
I thought it was so odd that baby “Ahhha”
in the song.
I’m like Timbaland is crazy.
He’s got this baby going in there but this
is a dope song.
So yeah…whatever year that was…1998?
I might have been?
That was 20 years ago?
So I probably was 28.
27-28.
Film Courage: Okay, what were your expectations,
when you were driving down the 101 (by the
way, the 101 scares me, too.
So I can see why.
But it’s also invigorating at night.
It’s so beautiful.
And there’s a sense of possibility you’re
like “Wow.
This is Los Angeles.”
But still it is scary.
What were your expectations at that time?
Choice Skinner: I thought in a year’s time
I was going to have probably five hit records
on the radio.
I was going to win an Oscar (not an Oscar,
a Grammy) and I would be able to buy my mom
a house.
Yeah…that was a rough time because for how
many years that I have been working on doing
music and having the success that I did have
and living in Georgia and having my songs
on the radio and stuff, when I moved to LA
that didn’t happen.
And it was just a rough time.
I mean I was living with the artist’s family.
I didn’t have my own place and it was hard
finding my place in that company.
And I was seeing where things were going to
be at that time.
So what you had on one hand, I had expectations
on where I wanted it to go but I was also
seeing where it wasn’t going to go.
And that’s tough especially when you are
working with someone so talented because you
say “Hmmm.
I see where you’re headed and it’s not
good.”
And if that’s where you’re headed what’s
going to happen to me?
Everything happens for a reason.
You know I look back at my music career and
I say man…and I still love music.
If I had an opportunity I probably would work
with somebody and come out with an amazing
record.
But I didn’t get the love that I get in
film, I didn’t get that love in music.
And so you have to go where the love is reciprocated.
As much as I love music, it wasn’t loving
me.
As much as I love film, it loves me.
And that to me…you know it’s like any
relationship (you know what I mean?).
It can’t be one sided.
So my expectations were I assumed I would
have at least five songs on the radio.
I was that good of a music producer and a
songwriter.
But it wasn’t meant to be and I had to accept
that, I had to accept that.
And making that transition helped me to move
into Film and Television.
Film Courage: We talked about early flexibility
and it goes back to Darwinism is the species
that survive are the one that adapt.
So you’re talking about you saw even though
you loved music, it was everything you wanted
to be, what was that moment like when you
realized…I mean how did you even see that?
How did you see as much as I love this, this
is me, it’s not going to happen.
Choice Skinner: I’m probably speaking the
tale of many people who got to that point
and quit the industry rather than making the
adjustment.
I think there is a point to where everyone
gets to in their life and goes listen, because
it’s really all about love.
All we are looking for as human beings is
love, we are all looking for it.
Some of us we find it in entertainment, some
of us we find it from our children, from the
spouse that we’re with, we find it from
our family, we find it from God, we find it
from religion.
We find it the way that we need to find it.
And when it’s not reciprocated, it’s a
very powerful and painful thing.
It was a cathartic moment for me.
I remember being on my knees and just crying.
And saying “God, why did you bring me out
here?
This is not going to happen.
What do I do?
Do I go back August?
Do I got to New York?
What do I do?
It’s not happening, I’ve been struggling.”
I was a personal trainer.
I was working at a gym.
I did so many different jobs.
But I think when you listen to that inner
voice (Oprah calls it the “aha” moment),
I believe it’s just an epiphany when you
wake up and you go "Maybe that’s just not
the way it’s supposed to happen.”
And if you let go, becomes sometimes God will
say “Be still and know that I am God.”
And I’ll go “Okay, what does that mean?”
What is that level of faith?
Understanding that if you wake up in the morning
that you are breathing, that you’re eating,
that you have the capacity of your limbs and
you’re still moving forward and you have
a roof over your head.
You have food to eat, you have clothes on
your back.
He’s giving you everything that you need,
so you just have to make that adjustment and
the adjustment for me was “Okay, music was
not the way.”
But getting into film (years later) needing
to work on the music which moves any film,
I had all of that experience.
And I said “Well, wait a minute?
That’s what that was for!”
So I snatched that big pearl and I took it
and put it into my big collection of jewels.
And now I realize okay now all of those years
of doing that, no different from me being
mugged or going through the violence that
I went through in Brooklyn as a kid which
got me into the martial arts.
All of those years of music, helps me as a
film director.
It helps me to teach my actors because they
don’t know 80’s music or 70’s music
or 60’s, and 50’s, and 40’s, and 30’s.
I know all about that because spent so many
years in music.
So now when I’m teaching them a little something
about acting, I’ve got a little extra resource
that I can give them through lyrics that they’ve
never heard because all they listen to is
current music.
Man…how powerful is that?
When I’m telling them “Hey listen to Bruce
Springsteen and he was singing this in this
song.”
Or listen to Richard Marx when he’s talking
about it don’t mean nothing.”
And this is attributing to your acting career,
your singing career or your dancing career.
And they’re going “Wow!
This is amazing stuff.”
They’ve never heard these songs, I have.